we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail about maybe i guess what we
would call it like a different approach
to getting single-payer health care
going take a look hi david my name is
rainy
I'm calling from Canada I don't have
time to get on your show so I'm gonna
leave you a message why is the United
States getting so hyped up over over
single-payer health it started in one
province in Canada one province and then
spread across the country
little by little it wasn't a massive
overturn in the country
it only had to start in one state
everyone could watch see how it works it
doesn't have to be a nationwide
experiment overnight to get your
thoughts on this yeah we'll listen Rini
you're not wrong but if there's one
thing history has proven to us it's that
just because Canadians are able to do
something logical doesn't mean Americans
are going to do it just because
Canadians and Australians and
Argentinians and the Swiss and the
Swedish and the Norwegians and the
Germans and the French and the Belgians
and I could go on right just because
they're all able to do something logical
does not mean that the United States is
able to on that basis and in fact
Vermont was going to do single
single-payer at the state level under I
believe it was governor Peter Shumlin
and it ended up falling apart for a
variety of different reasons so you're
completely right that I would love to
see Massachusetts actually do this
Massachusetts led the way we had
Obamacare before it was Obamacare was
actually Romney care and it was passed
by a very left-wing legislature and
these sort of centrist Republican
governor Mitt Romney I would love to see
Massachusetts do something like this and
I think we are a prime candidate to do
it you're completely right states could
do it but looking at other countries and
seeing them act logically and inferring
that the United States can do the same
thing historically has not been a very
good way to predict what we're going to
do here we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today two ways to
access it become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show great stories on the bonus show
including the disappearin
of Beto O'Rourke